welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz today i'm
really excited to be joined by ryan
clelin bogle who is the founder of
attempting ventures
between 2002 to 2009 ryan founded and
co-founded four recruitment brands
across different sectors and locations
which were finance healthcare and
retrorec which all operated across
london new york hong kong and ireland by
2013 it successfully exited all of these
brands and since then ryan's mission has
been very focused on supporting
mentoring and investing in successful
recruiting entrepreneurs he initially
started this journey as the ceo of
recruitment entrepreneur in 2014 but
then after this in 2017 ryan launched
tempting ventures which now actively
invest in early stage recruitment
businesses in exciting sectors in the uk
and us they currently have six different
recruitment brands within their
portfolio which they're looking to grow
which all operate in different sectors
and locations ryan thank you for joining
me on the podcast good to be here
so
uh as i always like to start this
podcast is the million pound question
but i'm gonna change it slightly for you
so
in your opinion what characteristics and
traits do you think make up a highly
successful recruitment entrepreneur that
let's start there okay um
i think in some ways it's pretty similar
to what makes someone a really
successful uh and sustainably successful
recruiter you know um
[Music]
as a starting point i think you know
what gives you a better chance of being
a successful recruiter or entrepreneur's
market so
um whether
some people get there by luck some
people buy good good judgment um we've
got there initially by luck and then
perhaps later by good judgment once we
probably understood how important it was
and but fundamentally you know if you're
in a good market and you
uh you know have it have a tailwind
the common threads that i've seen with
sort of you know successful recruitment
entrepreneurs is their ability to you
know attract train and retain talent and
you know that's the rule which is should
probably will never change for you
as the ceo for business so you know if
you can't
you know have a
magnetic or attractive vision for people
to join you if you can't give them the
training and personal development that
you know give them best chance of
success and you can't create a pathway
to keep them in your business you know
you you're probably gonna shelf life so
you know those those things i think are
the the common threads that people do
very well get right market attract train
and retain repeatably
and
that you know repetition is probably the
hardest challenge that recruitment
founders have you know at the start when
you're uh bringing people into a
business and you know maybe two of you
maybe three of you five of you
you know it's an opportunity to come and
sit with you learn from you you know
bastardize what you're doing get it to
work from you you know get lots of
personal attention whatever it may be
and you know all your language is in the
future
so we're going to be we're going to do
it's all going to happen you have any
question any of that you know um as you
grow a lot more of your language is
present some of it becomes past you know
it's great that you say you're going to
do this but you've been going six years
three of you you know so i love you yeah
and so
so i guess like that journey of a ceo
and how they attract training retain
people how how forward thinking uh
entrepreneurs are around that and how
how much they're able to put in
repeatable processes
matters
and you know it's a very very different
journey to go from 0 to 10 to 10 to 30
to 30 to 100 to 100 to 300. you know the
processes that you need to have in place
and what you need to value as an
entrepreneur needs needs to change along
the way
so if everything you do is driven by
personality you need to hear it see it
feel it touch it in order to understand
how it's working that will that will
slow you down at some point you'll
probably trip over if everything you're
doing is actually harder we repeat this
to give people a platform which is worth
more to them than my competitors you
know then you probably got quite a good
chance of success so you know that can
be l d that can be you know the
marketing and be able to demonstrate you
know x amount of our revenue came from
marketing which you don't personally
need to do next year it can be x amount
of our revenue data we already have in
our crm and own which you don't need to
supposed to do is already there so you
know we have something which is off
value people joining the business
and your aim should be to continually
build that value to make it a more
attractive proposition for people to
join you and that part of that's
obviously developing pathways and giving
people opportunity but the entrepreneurs
that are really focused on that
i think tend to do pretty well if
they're in a good market
and you know that is it's a pretty
common thread between each business you
get your operating model right is it
scalable is it buildable
um i think a lot of people struggle with
that because it's quite a different role
and you need to constantly be evolving
what you prioritize what your focus is
along the way
and you know i think quite often
culturally ceos find it quite hard to
get out of that liked mode in the
respected mode you know
people
and um
but you know the people that do that
well tend to be the people that flourish
i love that so much so much in there
i really like that simple like i guess
cornerstones of like attract train
retain i really i really like that super
simple yeah so
so let's so basically as i just said you
before obviously you've been in the
recruitment industry for some time now
and typically we would go into yeah when
you started your own business these
sorts of things but i really want to try
and maximize this time for people
listening and really go into
this journey that you experienced yeah
come by 2013 that a lot of aspiring
recruitment entrepreneurs visualize
maybe even think about or maybe even be
the reason why they start their own
recruitment business because they think
one day they'll be able to exit that
business so
i guess where i want to start is just
it's just going straight to that point
of like by 2013 you'd exited a number of
brands that you was involved with
started or co-founded yeah
and i think yeah a lot of people in the
industry may never even achieve or
experience one exit but you experienced
multiple so let's just stop there how
the hell did you achieve that like how
how was you able to achieve that
um
different businesses different results
really and i think with the initial
brand that we
found accounted for that was a a very
good market in the sort of first five
years that we were building the business
um
and you know it was pre
linkedin where you could leverage other
people's data so you know you really had
to build your own
and
the data that we amassed by staying in
very tight talent pools became very
valuable very quickly
and the
average fee the fee you know average fee
of the market that we were in rose as
the business was growing so you know we
had a sort of perfect storm a first
mover advantage and a really exciting
market for five years which enabled us
to get to
you know a level of scale in the
business and relationships with clients
repeatable processes l d finance et
cetera
so it would be a very difficult time in
2009 to 2012 but we we had a good enough
infrastructure and good enough legacy
relationships with you know clients
people
that you know we were able to
to ride that and get out of the other
side as the market came back
so i think you know we did a lot of our
learning during that period we got a lot
of things
wrong i think you know we
we probably had an attitude of like it's
our baby don't call it ugly and and so
you know because of that you know it's
very me too business you know where it's
like you know everyone kind of you know
sort of came in same you know graduate
program same l d you know
you know henry's just done 500 a month
you can do it too you know just do what
you do yeah
and you know i think that um
you know got us to a certain point but i
don't think we i think because we were
very young felt with the mind as touch
we probably weren't in listening mode we
were in talking mode for quite a long
time and it's probably only looking back
that we've realized that probably quite
a lot of missed opportunities there but
you know irrespective you know saw the
brand in 2012 and uh we had some other
brands around that that it made sense to
exit at that point in time because they
you know they probably work best as an
investor together
and so that was definitely a
probably in honesty probably as many
loans from that as it was that was wins
um with lupus love healthcare really
different uh experience so you know kind
of fox was you know huge average fees
you know yeah high end contingency bit
of retain a bit of search
uh lucas live healthcare was you know
private nursing agency temp recruitment
and you know so those common threads in
that you know love your candidates love
your attempts um but you know the
operating model was
you know pulls apart um
and you know lucas love healthcare was
probably a degree of right place right
time again you know we have
definitely had a very candidate short
market
probably didn't have the quality of
competition there are in other
geographies um and just a really
exceptional management team um i guess
that was the kind of point of difference
between kind of fox and microsoft
healthcare you know kind fox was we
built it it was our dna
lucas of healthcare was the dna of of of
two finders that you know i do well and
backed and so that was kind of quite a
learn in terms of how do you manage that
relationship to help them achieve what
they want to you know they want to out
of it
and you know that business actually in
the end probably did a bit better in
exit than uh you know a larger
contingency retaining business and so
you know it eventually sold to better
capital um
so like really different experiences you
know
your own dna one is uh sort of trying to
help people get the most out of those
but i think sort of by 2013 i sort of
felt like i you know built something
myself and uh with nick and you know had
a good result from it and
supported some other people and to get
the most out of their vision and had a
good result from it and you know the
question was you know actually could i
sort of blend that by by getting
involved and actually building the best
mid team that supports people and it
just felt like a pretty sensible move
from there yeah that makes sense yeah so
it's a couple of things
so first thing so just for context so
you mentioned the um the business that
um obviously acquired the healthcare um
brand was it this what was it the same
company that bought the obviously that
you sold to all the other
different different deals with different
people different transaction um
it sold a private equity business um and
the uh other businesses exiting
effectively mbos so
really really different uh experience
okay so the mbos okay cool because that
was definitely one of my questions so
okay a couple of things that i think
would just be interesting at this point
and maybe you could even you could say
obviously share how you did it then but
also maybe share how um things have
happened more recently but how did you
go about finding
these potential opportunities to get
acquired or like did you speak to
someone that then brokered like your
your business out to the market to
people that could be interested did you
have relationships with people that were
at pe firms or these types of firms that
you could potentially sell to like how
did you go about actually even getting
that opportunity like how proactive were
you um
it differs by brand um
you know i think it's about to revolve
aside what are you trying to achieve so
you know um
most recruitment transactions are a
glorified mbo you know so it could
either be on their driving trying to
help the management team that you know
they've seated and built and succession
planned around them tried access capital
for them to move the business forward
but the party risks their position and
leaves but effectively you know that's
managing an mbo and it can be led by the
management team who are approaching the
owners of the business and saying look
you know being a great journey to this
point would you consider giving us the
opportunity to buy ui leverage up our
position and you know build business
align with our dna our our ambitions so
and then you get sort of like something
like google's love healthcare which is
quite unusual where you get a management
team that uh managed to attract a buyer
where they just get out really quickly
and you know move on and uh and i'd sit
in the sun for a bit so that was quite
an unusual transaction in that regard
and i definitely you know that was a bit
of a beauty parade of speaking to
uh potential private equity investors
who felt that you know they could run
the vehicle effectively and so you know
that was a
unusual process in that regard in terms
of speed of exit um you know where it's
an mbo it's kind of understanding like
how do people's visions here align who
wants to drive the process
how do you do it symbiotically and you
know quite often if it's a if it's an
investor you know they'll probably want
to drive that you know they want to go
on and say okay we're going to talk to
other people in private equity community
and talk about you know how we can move
our position on whilst giving the
management team a better opportunity to
move forward with the mixture of equity
and more debt in the business to be able
to grow more quickly
if it's finaled then they're probably
approaching the and so it's management
team net they're approaching the
investor and saying that you know we
would like that opportunity and then
it's actually can everyone agree
something that they think is is is
workable with so um but ultimately you
know most recruitment uh transactions
are a a sort of you know a a a ribbon
mbo in some way
yeah because that was just that was just
going to be my sort of just
sort of the next question really as we
go into this like in your experience in
the last i don't know five or so years
like how
like how off like how realistic is it
for
a recruitment business to achieve that
exit is it is it actually a lot more
common that you see now that it's
actually like you just said that yeah
that sort of glorified mba and i
definitely have more questions on that
but like from your from your lens like
in the last because obviously i feel
like the more and more i speak to people
like yourself and other people in this
podcast i think maybe i don't know in
the last maybe 10 years ago you might
have been like right i'm starting a
recruitment business because i want to
start wait and i'm going to exit it
right then how many people actually
actually achieve that but like how much
of that is actually going on in terms of
it being sold to a p firm or whatever is
it typically more the mbo side that you
typically see more often um okay so the
i guess
if the question is uh
how do you
um
you know is it very easy to get an exit
the answer is it's really easy to get
that
depends what you want for it um um if
the uh you know basically you pass the
business to your number two for a quid
go and exit and so you know i i you know
i think the question is if you're trying
to sell a business to
a private equity firm
you know is that easy no it's not
you know yeah and um
and you know if it was everyone would be
doing it and you know it
doesn't happen that often you know yeah
that's what i mean yeah and so you know
and it's really important to understand
like what is you know if you're thinking
about my
you know my aim is to build a business
that could sell to private equity well
i think you need to
push paul say well actually
is that true is that what i really want
because
you know if it's what i really want i'm
probably gonna have to build a business
that would be
very different the touch feel look a bit
process or be very different just
building it to you know be part of the
business that i already have a nice life
make some money you know have the car
the house whatever i want
so you know and everything that you do
as early as possible needs to be driven
towards presenting your business the
best possible
light and so you know understanding you
know the investor mentality
is pretty important in that so
you know if you know if you sort of step
back and maybe look from an investor's
lens you know i am running private
equity business and you know first up
you know it's uh i've raised a lot of
money you know it's not really my own
money um i you know need to demonstrate
that i can uh invest that money well
i'm part of giving people confidence to
invest in private equity further saying
that there's certain parameters that you
know we will invest in and so you know
one of that tends to be like what's you
know there's a certain level of ebitda
that beneath that we don't touch because
that you know investors people are
giving them capital probably feel like
that that's a risk profile we don't
really like yeah so it's really
important to understand like you know
with your if you're looking at speaking
to private equity you know what are the
parameters that they're looking for what
are the problems they've raised capital
from because if you don't fit into that
there's no point really in having a
conversation yet you know so
in terms of trying to get an exit in in
the short term
so you know and and if you think about
you know an investor like really simply
put you know if i'm buying a bit of art
i kind of want to put that in my wall
look at it
you know get a couple of material and
say oh do you like that and then 25 or
10 years time sell it at a profit
without having to do much if i'm buying
a classic car pretty similar drive
occasionally turn up it goes up value
sell it you know i don't really want to
have to be the mechanic
you know i don't really want to have to
rebuild it every six months
and you know so if you're
asking for premium price from private
equity firm you know you need to
demonstrate to them that this is a
business that will continue to grow in
your absence
yeah it's an awesome thing what's the
asset that's going to rise in value now
no private equity firm thinks they're
that lucky you know they they know that
they're going to have to work hard with
management to get best possible results
but they want to believe that what
they're buying is you know what they
think they're buying which is a business
that's going to continue to grow at some
pace without their input
and so you know you need to be able to
demonstrate that the business you're in
hasn't capped on a market there's other
market opportunities did you continue
you can continue to attract train and
retain staff post a transaction too
you know you need to demonstrate that
you've invested in the business enough
in the last couple of years for it to
continue to grow and actually what you
haven't been doing in the last couple of
years is not investing in the business
to make it look a problem yeah yeah yeah
we've broken it for the next person so i
think market really really matters were
you what value proposition your business
has you know it's kind of back to i'll
give you a very good example actually
there's
you know a
um i spoke to a private equity investor
in the u.s who called me up maybe five
years ago after a well-known transaction
um
which was you know the frank group
transaction and which was the work sorry
and you know when we were sort of having
a chat about sort of why you know why
why behind newcastle we should be
invested in spotify everybody you know
what what things that came with those
actually saw huge value in talent pools
so
the uh candidate pools that the business
had built
you know was actually seen as actually
that network that ability to network
into that qualified talent pool the size
and scale of the talent pool you know we
just see tremendous value in that
because we're really long it's off we're
really long in salesforce and with that
that ability to build a talent pool
which is probably bigger than anyone
else's in the space the investors saw a
huge amount of value in that took a huge
comfort and safety in that and so you
know it's about understanding what an
investor wants to see why they think
your business has a usp why they think
it's going to continue to grow and and
one of the you know challenges that has
you know
and one of the things i think it's
important for recruitment finders or
entrepreneurs to understand
is that you know the last 20 years has
you know some really impressive
successes of private equity investing in
recruitment business and continuing to
grow and develop and make money you know
and frank group's really good example
you know living bridge invested and
before that did incredibly well from
helping the founders build build a
business and moving forward that's just
example of really good private equity
transaction but there's also you know
so many private equity firms have
examples of you know investments they've
made in recruitment firms which haven't
paid out
yeah and it's not an asset heavy
business you know your your assets your
people they you know arrive at 95 every
day you know it's not like you're in a
fleet of cars that you know you're you
know or or a tech stack that you can you
know proprietary tech that you could
sell to someone else so
you know
investors needed a lot of confidence
that the management team you know that
if if there's people leaving the
business as part of the transaction and
that's not going to derail the business
from a culture perspective yeah you need
more home and you need a lot of
confidence that the management team that
is staying the other side of the
transaction have the ability and
capability to continue to grow business
yeah you know i think fundamentally
giving
investors that confidence and a surety
is is really it's really important and
then market marketing
you know
yeah or behind you yeah so i'm
definitely gonna one of the questions i
have for you is like in your opinion
what makes us smart market a smart
market right we'll go into that but just
to i guess because this is one of my
questions that i
prepared for just to i guess just like
sort of tie this all up because we've
spoken a lot around the pe
um path right and one of my questions
was around the
um i guess like what you were saying
like really understanding the key
parameters that um pe investors want to
see from your recruitment business right
so that that was one of the questions
that i know i've had uh recruitment
leaders ask me before like if i'm
speaking to people like you what what
are the key kpis that i need to
really have a grasp of that ryan the
investor is going to want to see and
know so let's say that we've got the
management team that people part we've
got that right um and i do feel like
that is why the whole like mbo thing is
more common because i've spoke to so
many recruitment leaders who are on that
path to wanting to exit and they lose
their purpose because they're like i
want to do deals
i miss that right so then so i
understand that people about why it's so
important so if i have got that nailed
i'm confident my management team i've
got my exit plan i feel like it's not
going to be reliant on me what are the
like key key kpis metrics
parameters that i need to really
demonstrate and showcase to show that
we've got great assets and it's a strong
place to be invested in i guess two
things now firstly i'd sort of you know
if you genuinely are talking to me it
was like along the way i feel a bit lost
because i'm starting to lose that you
know deal junkie mentality
you just need to reframe that and make
that you know the deals you do is about
attracting the best people to come join
your business you know that's your role
yeah fair nice after sales journey or
about going out to back other people to
acquire other businesses you know that's
your job now it's just changed you know
it's not clients candidates and
i think in terms of you know one of the
key metrics that somebody
you know should be mindful of or what
should they be trying to present um
it does depend a little bit on market
you know search is going to be
uh very different uh to uh you know
logistics 10 business but you know
broadly you know you need to it's you
need to be able to demonstrate trend so
you know what is my trend on sales
what's my trend and net free income and
what's my translate with that you know
how's that conversion looking and
changing along the way um you know and i
might continue to invest to achieve that
um what's my productivity for head how's
that tracking what's my head cut how is
that tracking how can i demonstrate
that's repeatable am i going to maintain
or grow that productivity per head
what's my margins you know are my
margins defensible are they growing as
we get better or actually in order to
maintain growth are we having to accept
lower margins along the way to get more
as our wholesale business investors
don't like margins going down because
they feel like they're just going to
have to keep working harder a little bit
every year to get the business around
still so you know margins matter and
debt for profile of the business is
important you know i think people do
understand that too if you're um all
private equity investors will want to
get someone else in beside them to help
finance the the deal and um you know so
you if your business is has a very uh
poor balance sheet is strewn with debt
you know that is going to come off your
your your your your enterprise values
what you actually get so you know
businesses will look at that how much
more debt can the business hold against
it it's either that it's important
database matter you know declines pay
report it um
the
uh business will also want to see that
our private equity investor will also
want to see that there is you know i
think one of the big things a lot of
private equity folks look at speed
competency
so yeah sorry competency competency so
you know is and and
one thing i look at i see a lot asked is
you know people are
you know
certainly you've got you know 50 fee
owners and you know quite often
when you actually look at a 50 year old
or 100 feet under business so say you
know average productivity is you know
average 12 000 pounds impressive twenty
thousand pounds whatever it may be
and that's factually correct you know
there's a hundred people the averages
the average is twenty
but actually if you look at the median
you know it's actually fourteen because
you know there's kind of 10 guys
producing 50 of the revenue right
investor won't want to see that you know
what they actually really want to
understand is what what does the average
person
not what's the average you know so
what's not the average number someone
chooses actually what does the average
person in this business
achieve and so you know that's really
important because investor will look at
that and think there's a lot key man
risk
in that and you can't demonstrate to me
that you can get sort of 50 60 70 of
your people to a certain level you could
only actually demonstrate that you can
get 20 percent 20 yeah
i think that's really important to be
mindful of that because it will it'll
come up you know so i think there are
the key things that um
they
you know an investor will want to see
like what's the trend lines and those
things yeah
and then just just quickly real
practical here from your experience what
are like what's like
what should be recruitment business
owners be like let's like what's like
the i guess first major milestone with
their ebitda for them to even be like
okay maybe we need to actually like if
their goal is to
achieve some sort of exit right or
transaction like where like at what
point do you think ebitda was can they
then actually just really start thinking
about maybe we should actually start
having conversation i don't know what's
like that like what i know you said
earlier like if it's below a certain
thing it probably won't even be looked
at so i'm just curious as to like what
you typically see that ebitda being at i
know there's so many other factors
because you just shared but i guess
typically that you've seen i can answer
that specifically private equity because
you know along the way if you're
thinking about sort of raising money or
some kind of transaction like at any
point you can go to a bad grade some
money and you know at any point you can
get maybe an angel investor or someone
like put some money in along the way
because they believe in you and your
your product and your vision and so i
think you know it's very
the reality is that you know from your
first idea you know that i'm gonna you
know perhaps go and set up my own brand
to 100 000 pounds of profit to 300 to
400 you know at all points you have
options of you know either taking you
know debt into the business or that
equity mix whatever it may be so you
know i don't think that there is a hard
and fast
rule that somebody needs to get a
certain level before they yes or you
know should this just be the me show um
but i think you know if you're thinking
about a private equity
transaction it kind of goes back to what
they raised capital on
and you know one million ebit is a
pretty sort of you know well-known floor
kind of low market private equity and
that's one to three million ebay to low
market you know mid market from there
and then sort of you know you get sort
of like a the huge that uh
as well that would touch anything it's
probably less than ten you know so yeah
um so you you know you kind of need to
know your audience and and part of the
reason that private equity firms just
aren't really there and stuff that's
less
is that really twofold it probably feels
like there's still a bit of keyboard
risk at that point you know if you're
playing with sensitivity to sales that
probably fall down quite quickly
um but the second reason is that they
find it hard to blanket they find it
hard to get you know an hsbc or another
high street bank to come in besides and
put that into funding yeah less than
that level so you know it's sort of
understanding that
you know the question is you know if you
can get two million yourself you know
maybe you can get two or three before
you need to go and have that
conversation because it's only getting
easier again you know the higher level
of even that you have believe it or not
the more investors are in the market and
so
i'll hire multiple where you you know
get a better result so you know but
really private equity sort of millions
probably mark is it yeah fair enough and
what what has been the typical multiple
that people been able to achieve in your
career like whether you've seen so far
really is it really varied okay
um
i guess she's trying to get because i i
feel like so i mean there'll be so much
i don't know just like chat in the pub
and like he's m he's got this much blah
blah blah so like i just i think people
are interested like what do people can
actually people achieve what multiple
can they achieve you know
it is very very it's very by by
geography it's very bisector um it's
very much scale of business um
and actually it's varied by just timing
you know um yeah you know at the right
point of the cycle and there's you know
three or four private equity businesses
uh interest in the staffing sector and
probably a slightly better multiple than
you're right at the top of the market
and they're thinking you're probably
applying this card to this there's no
one else at it so
you know i think timing um
you know timing and scale are probably
the two things which impact multiple the
most um
in terms of you know what's realistic
you know i think if you're looking to
get any kind of exit multiple
you know
really
it grows quite quickly from maybe three
to four million even that so um
that sort of that kind of age-old you
know we need to be seventy percent
contract thirty percent perm to get you
know the right mix of multiple i'm not
sure that's as real as it as it once was
and i think people are
investors probably look at quality of
earnings um a little bit more uh you
know a little bit more ruthlessly than
they do the mix of earnings um
these days um but once you get to three
or four million leave a dime you really
shouldn't be doing anything less than
sort of six to eight times um you know
once you get to ten minute ebitda you
definitely should be doing less than ten
yeah okay thanks for sharing that so
final point on this because you've
mentioned quite a few things from
headcount ebitda nfi
time to competency i guess the question
i just had like if you were to like the
the question is basically from an
investor's point of view
like what would you if i'm listening to
this right now
like what would end up being from your
point of view like the most valuable
part of the business out of interest
like if we were to zoom in and like
maybe one particular area that could
impact other things in recruitment
business
what would you say is the most valuable
part of the bit of a recruitment
business would you say if we were to
really get it right
by person or function um i don't know
i don't know whatever it comes up to
leadership you know leadership yeah
that's against that you know and so you
know when we're looking marketing
leadership you know when we're looking
at making investment you know it's about
really getting to know
the management team and being you know
really open about our our relationships
our interests or wants and you know
desires aligned here and you know
fundamentally you're backing the leader
ideally and to
um be able to execute on what he says
his vision is and trying to help him do
that so you know as an investor leader
is huge i mean yeah really huge and you
know the leader is the point of spirit
and yeah you know you've got to believe
that the leader has it in the locker to
continue to grow and develop and thrive
and uh
and you know as the business grows but
you also need to be able to believe that
they've got a survival mentality too if
things get tough you know so
and they're two very different things
you know and last year
you know different year for a lot of
people right and um and really really
interesting the people that you know
survives in that market and you know
managed to keep the team together get
through
aren't necessarily the same people that
would really thrive in the best market
you know so ideally you're looking for
somebody that you know can you know
growth and survive to thrive but if they
need to you can survive and you don't
know which bone where the backbone
should be and leadership huge um and
then i think after that you know in
terms of function um you know we've got
a dd tool called rts that we use when
we're looking uh it's called scores
business out of
uh points and we're really trying to say
where's the area's improvement if we
invested you'd work with help um i think
sort of functions that we
you know would um
probably be most interested in and place
a lot of value in uh probably marketing
in lmd
yeah i mean i think it's an investor a
finance function is something that you
know uh you know provided it's fit for
purpose you know you can add value to
you know um you know governance hr
provided a fit for purpose you know you
can add value to you know talent
attraction l d and marketing i mean i
think that they're really really aligned
to the dna of the business you know so
what you're really looking at how are
those i mean are they good are they
getting a lot of value from marketing
you know are they positioning the
business well what revenue do they
generate for marketing clients accounts
right is that repeatable what's the time
the traction process like what's the
retention like you know how do they
onboard how do they induct you know is
that people and then l d you know like
what is if you strip away the kind of
management of the people we're talking
to every day you know who's coming
through and hospice is helping them come
through do they have a good track record
of doing that and so i think like by
function you know talent traction lmd
and marketing would be something that
you know we would be
uh really encouraged if we saw those
that was operating well
yeah okay cool so
really okay so i guess this would be a
nice segue then into like you said like
having you said leadership first right
so i guess
let's sort of take this into the
direction of yeah maybe a bit more down
the sort of mbo route and a few a few
other questions that i have for you but
um this question comes up a lot right
because i do feel like a lot a lot of
growing recruitment leaders and agencies
i do really find it hard to have that
layer underneath them or like obviously
yeah cultivate those leaders within the
business
so i guess my first question is
like in the typical businesses that you
sort of see do this well or a business
that you think is in a really strong
position like what does the typical like
org chart look like from a leadership
perspective out of interest like how is
it i don't know how how do recruitment
businesses typically um have their sort
of management layer within the business
and how does it typically operate just
out of interest like what are the
typical org charts that you see
um
i just completely
changes by i did that fair enough scale
um
you know i'd expect it to look very
different at 300 people than 30 you know
until of course see your job is that i
think like the big
the big thing for me is actually sort of
going back to leadership fits into
whatever you're going to have reported
into you when yeah you know that's kind
of about a leader understanding
what job is and
and that should change
as the business grows so you know i most
people can relate to when they set up
for business you know your job is
literally everything you know and i'm
sort of sort of all at the above and you
know you're sort of struggling to uh
find the time to speak to clients and
candidates because you're sending out an
invoice and you're interviewing somebody
going to join the business and then you
join us contract and then you're talking
about your great lmd program while you
write the first module the day before
you give it to them
so you know and as time changes you know
ceo needs to go actually how do i in the
next 12 months since i'm writing my
business plan for that year you know how
do i impact this business best and what
do i need to let go and who do i need to
bring in do i need to let go yeah and i
think you know one of the
things which really
slows uh a business growth is you know
if you kind of think about the mentality
of a recruiter it's you know good
recruiters are quite controlling by
nature
yeah yeah for sure so you have to be you
know i've got a candidate here i've got
clients here you know my job is to
influence that process you get them to
successfully date and so you know i'm
trying to manage that process control
that process to get a positive outcome
i'm god i can do it you know i can make
everything
you know i'm the best influencer etc
and so you know your mentality is you
come up through equipment it's very
controlled control control don't leave
anything to chance look wrong quarters
and actually if you start to build a
business you know that slows the
business down you know if you try and be
god and you're trying to come up with a
solution for everything you're not
trusting people you're not bringing the
best people in listening to them
then actually it becomes very very
difficult to start a business because
you end up in that place if you're just
there's too much food control
and you actually end up doing everything
averagely
stepping in everyone's toes and not
doing anything well because actually
you're not prepared to let go and bring
in people who know more than you about a
function who can do it better actually
learn how to have a good relationship
and manage that person by listening
and you know i think that slows down a
lot of recruiting business but they
never get to that big old chart because
actually the finder couldn't let
anything go they feel uncomfortable
letting anything go
and you know part of that is
mentality but part of that is also you
know what
um
it's comfort and
because if i'm a recruiter i've done
that job so actually i find it quite
easy you know
something else to do or manage someone
else to do it because i can relate i've
done it you know i think recruiters
quite often in the building of business
they really struggle to let go because
they actually struggle to manage other
functions because they've never really
done it themselves or certainly haven't
done it to this to the level yeah it's
really interesting it's the person
and so you know i think that kind of
letting go and trusting attracting the
best people and then creating a
framework where they can influence the
business to enable you to move forward
and focus on where you can impact the
business best and you know could get you
to a point where you've got a really
great old chart which is effectively you
know i've got my uh you know key
directors whether it's by geography or
division that you know reporting to me
and sales and how they're doing you know
i've got my head of marketing here which
is reporting how he's working or she's
working with key stakeholders to drive
value i've got hr and lnd who are
talking about you know actually what's
our was where's the performance
improvement opportunities what do we
need to get better you know talent
attraction which is making sure that we
can repeat this process and come into it
and you know those people that you
should be
uh have around you in a little chat
probably quite close to you you know
yeah i think as the business grows then
there's a probably strategy point isn't
there you know a lot of businesses will
will
and look to either have somebody focus a
strategy to bring in a sort of chief
strategy officer which helps you sort of
tie together all those to achieve your
goals
and i think that sort of like if i was
looking at normal chart that's kind of
broadly what you yeah no that's great
thank you so i think you i feel like you
just sort of answered this but i want to
ask it because as i'm sure you're well
aware a huge um portion of the uk
recruitment industry is very much made
up of micro small businesses right
under 10 heads 20 heads or whatever now
i'd like to think even that's a high
percentage from the conversations that i
have i don't know if you'd agree i would
i would think that quite also let's say
it's eight percent of the uk recruitment
market i would i'd probably like to say
at least half or maybe even three
quarters of those recruitment leaders
actually want it to be
bigger than it is right or have
motivations to do that not everyone
wants a 20 30 40 person business but i
would i do feel like they have
aspirations they have big goals but
because of various things one of them
being what you just shared they may
never actually get there so a real
common question i always get in my inbox
for for me to ask the people that have
breaking through those sort of
sort of really difficult barriers of
like getting over 30 heads getting over
20 heads or 40 heads so that was the
question really and i feel like you may
have answered it a bit but i guess the
question is for any founders listening
to this who are at that 20 person stage
that do have aspirations they've got a
vision that they want it to be bigger
like what what other advice would you
give them to to break through
that that milestone that barrier that is
maybe yeah things that may be preventing
them from getting past it have
interested is there anything else on
that yeah sure churn kills you
you know with your small but
yeah absolutely throttles you yeah yeah
i obviously turn for your own business
you're quite a small team you know you
see you see a lot of businesses where
you know they
start off with one or two people go to
five or six back three seven yeah yeah
up to nine back to two back to six
and you know but my question would be
like what part do you have to play in
that like what are you learning from
that because it keeps happening you know
um you know i suspect the common thread
you
and so
you know and and really why why is it
happening because the
uh
you know the founder isn't being
disciplined enough
on the uh you know basically what's my
business business and how do i stay
disciplined to that so you know if you
are i think when you're very
opportunistic and this is really hard to
execute on easy advice to get but
you know when you're opportunistic in
nature
and when you've got uh early stage
recruiting business you know
we do software developers but someone's
just throwing a project managing rules
well it's like yeah
like all that's doing is taking you
further away from your purpose you know
that's not repeatable the work you're
doing this week isn't that values next
week so like really try and make sure
that every single person touches your
business the work they're doing this
week you can extract value off the
future and you know for me that's by
really staying tight the market tighten
the talent pool where you know the value
that becomes value creative and people
that join the business at whatever point
have a better chance of success in the
future and so that's really huge for me
like don't be too opportunistic in who
you're hiring or i know you know we're
sort of doing software developers but
jeff's a great accountant finance
recruiter i've worked with him before
and i really trust him yeah once you
bring him into software development
don't make it too hard and so you know
try and stay ruthlessly focused and
setting up one business one specialism
one thing that you can become have a usp
at create value in be best
the second you try and go too wide too
early you you're not actually you know
of course people want to as they grow
their life but actually that's a
repeatable process we've done it in one
market we're gonna do it another you've
nothing eating if you're trying to do
two or three markets at the start and it
very rarely works and you know more
often than not you see it sort of the
sale to one market several years later
so you know that'd be really strong
advice to that you know the other thing
is that don't hire and hope
and you know i see this like uk
recruitment businesses specifically
are not great at this you know they um
they tend to
[Music]
they tend to see head kind and success
is inextricably linked
so you know if we get other five people
in there would be 15 not 10. but
that distracts the 10 people you have
from going from good to great
that's a really poor decision you know
like try and get to great and then grow
try and hire into desks that are warm
where basically you're missing our needs
missing out on opportunities if you
don't hire you don't have you know
lukewarm deaths i think well if i hire
this hero he'll make it really warm
because if you can't get the people you
have performing diluting that reading
your time your energy is only going to
diet performance and so i think people
try and grow too quickly and and it's
back to that kind of you know um you
know what's the average performance
what's the kind of medium performance
you know quite often you know someone
will get six eight or eight heads and
then look at go oh brilliant you know
we're doing 80 grand a month that's all
right you know we made 25 grand last
month and you know so probably we could
hire another three or four people on the
back of that
but actually the kind of tan heads they
have only three of them are consistently
performing
so whilst you are making money and
whilst it kind of looks good in that
little spreadsheet that you've done
the truth is most of your business are
performing so get them performing then
grow make it repeatable can i am i
repeating what i did before to grow
and you know that is like really like i
can't give that console strongly enough
stay tight and you know and also like
you and this is pretty pretty
um
pretty ruthless thing to say but people
hire too easily
you know like it is hard to hire people
you know get good at it
you know so you know don't hire bees
hoping they'll become an a you know say
like i'm in a a
rc's i'm gonna hold on an interview hard
behind you until i find somebody [ __ ]
great and because i've really had to
earn that higher i'm going to really
value that
i'm going to work with them so hard to
get them working
and you know so like really high bar
talent attraction you need to be clear
on who you're looking for and then you
can't sort of settle for someone
different or change your mind on that
because just find a bit easier yeah yeah
that's really good you're really strong
on that and then you know once people
are in the business you need to be
honest with them
you know like actually this is my
expectation
you know at this point in time in our
journey
as we perform my expectations could have
changed go up but i do need you to do
this
and if people don't you've got to in and
out quickly because it devalues your
business to everyone else if you're
sitting with like three people who are
really really before me but seven people
are still sitting there aren't now what
is that
and so you know you need to be able to
make strong decisions to make sure that
you're trying to create a core where
everyone's exceptional and if you look
at you know businesses that i think you
know the you know obvious businesses
that have been involved in you know any
kind of
you know transaction or event in the
last number of years when it's frank
group of fade and spencer whatever core
is exceptional yeah of course so
i think this is a good question to ask
so i want to make sure we ask around
because i feel like this is something
that
even when me and you started speaking
you like really spoke a lot about this
around the sort of smart markets piece i
want to make sure we speak about that
because i know that's big for you guys
attempting ventures so just before i do
that i think this perfect time to ask
like
what i hear a lot of recruitment leaders
struggle with
is yes everything that you're saying but
and then understanding what their hiring
triggers are i feel like you're talking
a bit about it there where you get your
core people who are missing leads
they're missing out on opportunities and
then try and get in rather than as you
said i really like that instead of
thinking oh if we got someone in then
they would probably do better or it'd be
go from lukewarm to warm i really like
that so i don't know what i like
i don't know is that science behind
hiring triggers because i feel like a
lot of people struggle with that like
you said there's a few things so i think
you know try and uh so don't do it by
your overall business you know so you
know if you are at you know 15 people
and you've got sort of two teams you
know
don't because you're a sort of 15 grand
bread don't you think we're hiring
everywhere you know if one team's at 20
and one teams are 10. higher into the
wallets 20 don't try and get 10 to 20.
that's you know it's like follows
all of what's working and you'd be
really surprised that actually a lot of
people don't follow us because they want
to win everywhere and it's just far
quicker to follow what wins and try and
get it to critical mass so you know i
think that's important to separate all
right so you can look at it um i think
you know it's
when your business is
relatively small average productivity
can be a real red herring you know you
do really want to look at if i stripped
out the top two or three people where
everyone else what's the average there
yeah you know if that's you know at a
level which is exciting you should
probably be hiring um but if it's not
it's only the top two or three that make
it look exciting i you know i try and
get get the rest up make the tail up
that's pretty important
um and then actually the other thing is
you know speed competency so you know
that's something i really try and track
early in a business because it should
get better and if it's not getting
better i would be concerned if that's
trending the wrong way so you know when
you were five people and you're all
working really tightly together you're
hiding the junior or an experienced tire
and you know within three weeks they
interviewed with six weeks to make the
first placement that was pretty
consistent but that's not three months
and you know i'd be starting to look at
that and go should we be hungry do we
have something that we need to address
here because speedy companies are still
done before we are because we're not
having the best chance of success when
they when they arrive
so they're the things that i would be
i love that yeah i love the speed of
conversation i really like that so right
final question and then let's sort of
finish this up with
just really focusing on
yeah um
tempting ventures smart people smart
markets because i'm really curious about
this so the the final um put on this
because i do get this a lot and various
reasons why i think people struggle with
this is one
don't know how to find people that
haven't had the best experiences with
people but the question is that i get a
lot of the time which i want your
thoughts on is like all of these things
that we spoke about in the last 45
minutes um obviously could potentially
be
um easier or you would make less
mistakes if you were working with
someone or had some sort of mentor ned
to help you ride this
journey right
um and i've seen you talk about that i
think one of the old videos of
recruiting entrepreneur whereas you're
like look if i had access or help i
probably would have achieved an even
better multiple or got there quicker
right
so i know a lot of people want
like that sort of help as i said a few
different reasons why they don't end up
but like i don't know how can how can
people listen to this
find credible
nds and mentors like how to approach
them how to find them what's your advice
on that um
oh it's it's just so
it's so situational and
i
i've got a lot of thoughts on it so
you know i guess the irony of you know
particularly early stage investors is
you know they're probably looking to
invest in someone that doesn't really
need investment to do well you know it's
worth investing could they do
exceptionally
and
you know quite often the very best
people don't really believe they need
the investment or the help because you
know everything they've done has worked
so far so you're actually getting uh you
know best people best investors together
early stage you know the likelihood of
that probably quite slim you know and so
you know so you know investors need to
uh work they need to conscious of that
and you know work hard to make sure that
um you know visions are aligned um
and
i think you know
recruitment entrepreneurs need to be
i need to really understand what taking
investment means you know because
you've got kind of i can take investment
or i can take some advice
you know
or i could be in a network you know
you've got lots of different options
it's too hard to get console to grow
your business so you know you need to be
very very clear on what you're looking
for
okay and why and you're
like is it realistic you know because
like investors
want to work with management teams that
are going to be you know like ruthlessly
focused and trying to you know achieve
their potential of building a business
that is best in class of what it does
and so you know
that honesty in relationship really
matters um i think there are you know if
you look around the market you know
there's probably quite a negative
you know connotation about the idea of
recruitment investment um
and because you tend to sort of hear
like in anything you know where it
hasn't worked right it's quite a loud
voice same with the ned's as well i
always hear it like they just don't
really do much not very proactive just
sit on our board meet in every four quad
charge 500 700 quid a month yeah but you
know my question would be what's your
part to play in that and what part yeah
because you know if you're not driving
value from an nd and if you're not
listening to the eyes or you're making a
decision early and saying you're not for
me you know more stories getting a bit
boring you know i've learned 80 of what
i'm going to in the first 20 of the time
and you let that go for another year or
two years and start learning about the
led but actually yeah
you know and so you've got to be
selective and i think one of the you
know one of the uh things i think is is
a common thread is that i think you know
investees don't do enough dd and
investors
and uh quite often recruitment business
foreigners don't do enough
work to find the right ned and through
dd on their any due diligence yeah
exactly and you know so and it's kind of
very similar to like hiring great people
can work for you you've got to work
really hard to find the right people to
come and join your business you have to
work really hard to find the right led
you know you've got to kiss a few frogs
and and it's exactly the same with
investor you know it's going to be the
right mix it's got to be the right mix
of fuel to get it to ignite so you know
investment for investment's sake is a
waste of time it's about actual honesty
of like actually you know what are your
goals can we help you do them do we
understand what each other's rules are
going to be in that are we happy to
write that down and then we're happy to
be beholden to it and you know we both
have to work hard to deliver on it
you know if that conversation isn't
happening probably shouldn't be taking
investment and
and you know i think it's it's you know
and i think founders need to understand
they do have a part to play quite often
where an investment falls over or it
doesn't work out with an ned like they
were in the room too
and so you know i'd really console
founders whether it's an nd whether it's
an investor you know don't
phone up all the people that are in
their existing portfolio don't phone up
the people that they're working with at
the moment phone up the people that you
used to work with you know phone up the
investments that didn't work phone up
the ned that you did two years ago and
say look you know what the positives
what the negatives what advice is yeah
and because
an investor or an ned should want that
really you know relationships they have
in the background you know with uh
perhaps businesses that that haven't
scaled with them or you know there's
been a party of ways like that
relationship still isn't a good one
you know and it isn't positive to say
you'd probably take
something to be said though yes yeah you
know
so i think like you know but you know i
think the that that it completely
depends what point you're at i don't
think broadly
um you know you should look to take an
ned too early in your business um i
think you know it's got to be your dna
at the start and you know it's pretty
obvious the things i think you need to
do to get business to 10 stay focused
hire great people focus on the get your
productivity there stay in the market
look at market
like after that is a different journey
to get to 10 30 and i think it probably
would be starting to look at maybe is
kind of right so someone who's done that
reasonably recently
or has worked with the business that's
done that recently recently you know um
because you know there's kind of war
stories for somebody did it 25 years ago
i'm just not sure
yeah yeah i'm just in the last 18 months
24 months
you know yeah yeah we've got a really
understand text that really understand
marketing got to really understand you
know because you know if you think about
sort of recruitment broadly you know 40
years ago was i'm setting up a you know
recruitment business in reading and
anyone a three mile radius i'll find
your job you know now it's you know like
sort of right now to signify you know
i'm only going to look at scala
developers i'm going to do globally
anywhere we can do it anywhere because
technology enables us to do that like
whole recruitment business operates and
models and how people become you know
remote working and how they fit together
and work together and what methodologies
have to do that like that's really the
point you're playing in now you know not
500 people in one office you know you
know basically we'll do a bit of
anything uh 30 40 years ago so it ain't
like that kind of currency of of doing
it recently matters for either an nd or
investor yeah love that just before i
ask you the final question we'll end on
the um tents inventions piece just a
quick sort of quick fire question really
because i feel like in your journey you
would have seen um a lot of different
tools and tech that you'd invested in
like in your opinion what are like the
tools or tech that come to mind that
like you would as a recruitment business
owner you would not want to be living
without out of interest
that come to mind just really quickly
yeah i think we do a really good cra
matters i mean we're we're using venturi
across the businesses um
and uh i'm impressed with the product i
think it's continuing to evolve so give
it a thumbs up um but you know you do
need to make sure that chair bought
through um uh something with one sales
which is going to enable um one lab
sales yeah to
you know get a better quality or or of
management data for the for the
consultants too nice um i think you know
that's probably encouraged um i think
there's a great product i think it's
called conquest which enables uh actual
people to probably look at their forward
earnings and like kind of manage that
and see it and understand what
characters could be like i think that's
really empowering um so i think that's
important you know linkedin's a pretty
obvious one but i think you know
the question using linkedin is how do i
get into linkedin you know get the
information off it and then live in my
data and you know so i you know i think
linkedin is kind of you know it is a
necessity but i think if you're if
you're if your business is always on
linkedin all day and at the expense of
your own crm you know all you really do
with mining the same database is you
know x amount of announcements
so you know it's about trying to get it
off that with better quality of data
that's all they did under your crm where
you understand people's wants needs and
vicious dreams yeah loads of different
tools you can do that isn't there like
lead our queue loads different things
exactly and we personally won't put
anything in our crm unless we've you
know spoken to the candidate length have
um
you know i have personal details um if
we do with that if that hasn't happened
and there aren't significant notes
keep working harder to have that
conversation yeah you really want is
your crm to be your your everest with
really great data and better quality
around anywhere else and one thing i
would say depending which market you're
in you know i think talent insight's a
really valuable tool if you're in sort
of search space and yeah i've heard
that'd be really valuable with yeah and
such projects really really really good
tour but you get you get out of it what
you put into it you know
and but you know we've definitely seen a
lot of of of wins from you know making
sure that we work that data well and um
and so you know and there are some of
the key things then obviously yeah nice
girls rip the market back out of your
crm effectively and automate that
i love that so let's
let's send it here then tempting
ventures where where are you going
you're as as i love the statement on
your website we back smart people in
smart markets
yeah that's what we're being recruitment
brands where are we taking attempted
ventures yeah well we've got we've got
quite a few um brands that are
uh either in the uk and us or operating
in the us from the uk and operating in
germany from the uk we think this great
opportunity to to land and expand so
we're expecting that in the next year
just in process of finalizing investment
in the u.s and in scientific market um
which we're really excited about which
we expect to grow quite quickly next
year
and we
expect to i've got a brand we've
invested in a search brand called
eastwood which we think is going to grow
pretty quickly in new york i think it's
a great opportunity to
uh actually acquire other brands and uh
alliance spaces beside it so yeah
respectfully make quite a few
investments the next 12 months it's been
a good ride recently but
our priority at this point you know is
to only invest in businesses that you
know we
really really believe in because
actually we've got a great opportunity
invest time in the businesses that we've
already invested in and you know we're
really excited about we're going to go
yeah i love that um
and then look final question
um is just
obviously an industry that
has obviously given you obviously been a
big part of your life has obviously
given you a lot like what if you could
change the industry what would you
improve
um
that's a really hard question right i
think you know
um
you know i guess you know it's very you
say well i you know which was more
honest industry
really because actually all the people
that are very honest and sort of
actually probably give me a bit of a usp
so yeah
i kind of feel like you know i should be
telling you i wish it was more
transparent than we're always but
actually i think that's your opportunity
isn't it because it's not really
um
you know i think the uh
i think the
yes i think that's important um that i
think uh there's a lot a lot of small
cameras in the business i think people
need to
take a much more collaborative approach
and more open approach i think that is
happening with different networks uh you
know
definitely more collaborative and less
combative than the market was
historically um so i guess you know
that's um
that's one thing and then the second
thing is just actually confidence um i
think a lot of recruitment businesses um
actually don't have the confidence to
value the great service that they offer
and
you know um
might seem you know a bit hard to say
but you know if i'm deloitte or pwc you
know bring someone into my business
which is basically i photo recruiter
and then you know i happily performed
that personality declined in a 300
portion
because i've got the brand it's not
really doing much different you know but
recruiters sometimes you know struggle
to have the strength this actually we
added a huge amount of value and you
know we are confident in that and we
don't feel you know in any way ashamed
of guilty for the value that we had
because you know the market in the next
few years the
uh place recruiters have in that market
um is only going to grow in importance
the market you know most markets which
are in any way technology facing are
becoming more and more candidates short
and you know in the absence of a
relationship or relationships with great
recruiters you know any business will
struggle to grow thrive survive and so
you've got a really important part to
play in the economy and you know we need
sort of things like fundamentally people
businesses and we're here to try and
match the best people the best
businesses and so like you know we
really do have part play and it's
important part and i think you know
businesses need a little bit more
confidence and how they
uh articulate that but also how they
charge for it because um you know i
think the recruitment you know the
margin
probably spent the last 10 years a
little bit of margin erosion you'll
actually bring back the other way now
yeah love that ryan been an absolute
pleasure
uh thanks so much for joining us on the
podcast and um really enjoyed that
thanks a lot okay